dans votre vie vous avez plus souffert
du racisme anti noir ou du racisme anti
TF1
invité principale ce soir c'est Harry
Roselmack
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes présentateur
du 20H sur TF1 présentateur du Sept à
Huit le dimanche ainsi que de l'émission
Harry Roselmack en immersion
présentateur du journal inattendu le
samedi à 12h30 sur RTL
point martiniquais vous bossez beaucoup
quand même non
protestation des Martiniquais qui sont
dans la salle et puis vous êtes le
journaliste préféré des Français devant
Pujadas et de House
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et puis vous êtes l'homme idéal des
Françaises devant Noam Michalak et
Lizarazu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle raison ça militaire
alors arrive vous connaissez l'émission
on perd nous serons tous les deux nous
parlerons de vous de nos origines de
votre enfance de votre adolescence de
vos débuts de votre carrière jusqu'à
votre arrivée sur TF1 le choc un noir
sur TF1 qui n'était pas dealer dans un
reportage du droit de savoir
[Musique]
alors Harry rebonsoir donc incroyable
c'est votre vrai nom oui c'est mon vrai
nom ça fait non une scène un peu à Mac
non
vous êtes né le 20 mars 1973 à Tours par
an martiniquais maman guichetière au
bureau de poste de Tours Nord perceres
alors le père CRS a dû aider pour entrer
à TF1 non
alors des parents qui insistent sur les
vertus du travail vous ont toujours dit
qu'il fallait que vous travaillez plus
que les autres pour y arriver c'était
quelque part peut-être
l'expression d'une forme de complexe
parce que l'idée c'était de dire toi tu
es noir les autres ne le sont pas donc
pour y arriver tu auras besoin de plus
bosser que les autres
mais je pense avoir regardé en tout cas
le l'habitude de bosser alors vous avez
un frère consultant en informatique donc
Willy et une sœur qui travaille pour
Scotland Yard à Londres Peggy incroyable
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle gère une
équipe qui répond aux appels d'urgence
de police secours alors vos parents sont
repartis vivre en Martinique aux morner
rouge c'est ça et vous vous allez
souvent Martinique
passer on essaie de se voir une fois par
an alors comme vous étiez enfant vous
allez en Martinique tous les tous les
trois ans et alors comme vous alliez pas
à la Martinique les étés où vous restiez
en France vous travaillez à la poste
avec maman et qui remplaçant facteur
ouais j'ai fait quelques tournées avec
vélo à Tours Nord effectivement c'est
une ambiance très particulière un bureau
de poste il y a une collectivité de gens
qui travaillent derrière les guichets
que personne ne voit et il y a le il y a
le type qui fait rire tout le monde il y
a celui qui gueule tout le temps il y a
celui qui est toujours en pause il y a
des gens très différents et c'est très
marrant
alors avec votre première paye vous avez
fait un cadeau à votre mère c'est beau
ça vous l'avez offert quoi
alors le reste de l'année vous êtes un
lycéen très sage au lycée Choiseul à
Tours et le bac grâce au judo quand même
j'ai eu une maigre mention grâce au judo
d'accord mais je pense que j'aurais eu
mon bac sans judo alors quand vous étiez
en première au lycée vous faites de la
radio sur Radio Béton qui est une
radiocale de la communauté antillaise
donc à Tours vous faisiez déjà les flash
info je récupérerai sur un sur un hebdo
le France Antilles les news de voilà de
la Martinique de la Guadeloupe de la
Guyane et de la réunion je faisais mon
petit flash j'avais une cassette VHS sur
laquelle j'avais copié en boucle le la
boucle de France Info et que je m'étais
enfonce sonore pour faire comme si pour
de vrai mais vous commencez les flash
info sur Radio Béton aujourd'hui le
vainqueur de TF1 c'est pas mal
alors là il y a ce soir vous n'êtes pas
au journal de TF1 qui présente à votre
place Francky Vincent
conneries j'ai que des vannes pour rien
après vous faites un IUT de journaliste
et en 94 la chance se présente mais
c'est pas à Tours c'est à Paris à votre
mère voulait pas trop vous partiez quand
même hein
pour la première fois de ma vie j'ai
désobéi à ma mère à l'âge de 21 ans ou
rendez compte je pense que c'est ça je
pense que c'est vrai en plus
alors à Paris la radio s'appelleradio
médias tropicale c'est la radio des
dôméens pour l'Île-de-France et là vous
renouez avec vos racines antillaises
vous reparlez créole dites moi Thierry
je vous aime beaucoup en créole mais toi
et puis ensuite France Bleu France Info
vous refusez la météo sur TF1 quand j'y
Lopez s'en va malin ça correspondait pas
à ce que je voulais qui était de d'être
journaliste j'ai essayé de concilier les
deux j'ai essayé de négocier la météo
plus un boulot sur LCI de journaliste et
ça a été possible à l'époque donc j'ai
dit non vous avez eu raison ensuite
i-Télé Canal+ c'est là que j'ai connu
qui avait le plus à l'heure du déjeuner
et puis le 6 mars 2006 TF1 annonce que
vous serez le joker de PPDA est-ce que
vous saviez pas à l'époque c'est que
présenter le vainqueur de TF1 ça faisait
perdre ses cheveux
je les avais déjà perdu avant à ce
niveau là je courais pas grand risque
c'est vrai quand vous aviez des jeux
vous étiez coiffé comme Grace Jones il y
a longtemps il y a longtemps une espèce
de brosse bien carré comme ça il y a
longtemps mais ça a été à la mode à une
époque bien sûr je pense je suis sûr que
vos musiciens
j'avais été aidé quand même pour rentrer
sur TF1 par Club Averroès qui est un
club qui fait la promotion de la
diversité dans les médias français et
vous avez rencontré pour la première
fois Étienne Moujotte et Patrick Poivre
d'Arvor au club aveyro s alors vous êtes
contre les quotas mais vous êtes quand
même favorable à un contrôle de la
diversité dans les recrutements oui
parce que je pense qu'il faut vraiment
avoir une politique volontariste il y a
des mécanismes qui faut casser je pense
pas que que l'absence de diversité dans
les élites françaises soit
systématiquement liée à la à la volonté
de ceux qui qui recrutent de ne pas
prendre de noir de ne pas prendre de
Maghrébins de ne pas prendre
d'asiatiques parce qu'il ne les aiment
pas c'est juste que c'est pas naturel
c'est pas naturel et c'est mécanique là
de cooptation et de recrutement dans les
mêmes écoles dans les mêmes cercles il
faut les casser je pense par une
discrimination parce que moi j'appelle
une discrimination positive sans quota
et avec des contrôles et avec des
incitations c'est ce qui se passe en
fait nous producteurs de télévision nous
dit ça serait bien et non mais c'est pas
encore mesuré matique de recrutement des
chefs mais c'est déjà bien
qu'effectivement on se pose la
problématique là soit intégré dans votre
vie vous avez plus souffert du racisme
anti noir ou du racisme anti TF1
alors en tout cas grâce à vous on a fait
un grand pas dans la lutte contre le
racine parce qu'on a vu que des Noirs
pouvaient lire un promoteur
alors en 2006 7 à 8 avec Anne-Sophie
Lapix et puis ensuite en solo en 2008 en
2007 un bouquin novilus il est Bongo qui
est le nom de votre votre mère vous les
malvécu cette histoire du livre ah non
non moi j'adore ce livre j'en suis très
très fier c'est l'une des productions
l'une de mes productions dont je suis
plus fier mais son accueil vous l'avez
mal vécu quand même
non j'ai eu un épisode malheureux dans
une émission de télévision
bah ça s'est mal passé c'est vrai que je
m'attendais pas à un tel procès
stalinien de la part des des deux Eric
et voilà mais qu'est-ce qui vous
reprochez en fait ils ont été
extrêmement durs ils ont ils ont estimé
que le bouquin était mal écrit
ce que je conteste formellement moi je
vais encore une fois je suis extrêmement
fier de ce bouquin ils m'ont comparé
avec des auteurs qui sont des auteurs de
grande notoriété ce qui est pas très
cool quand même pas très cool parce
qu'évidemment moi je revendique pas le
talent de d'auteur qui qui ont une
oeuvre prolifique et qui se sont sans
doute construits pas forcément leur
premier bouquin mais peut-être alors 5e
6e donc voilà ils ont des procédés qui
sont pas très sympas mais bon
Zemmour maintenant vous savez pourquoi
alors
en 2009 RTL vous demande de faire le
Journal Inattendu et là vous avez énervé
Carla Bruni avec des questions sur cuir
stream elle a menacé de quitter le
studio elle avait raison les
journalistes qui posent des questions
c'est pas normal
c'était chaud
sur une émission du Nord ça a été chaud
pendant 5 minutes
on immersion le dernier numéro c'était
mardi dernier donc sur le salafisme ce
qui est très intéressant c'est qu'en
fait les lois qui régissent la vie de
ces gens-là ne sont pas les lois de la
République il respecte la loi de la
République lorsqu'elles ne sont pas en
contradiction avec une prescription
religieuse c'est à dire que la
prescription religieuse prendra le pas
sur la loi de la République et c'est en
ça qui sont fondamentalistes tout ça
pour aller au paradis leur truc c'est
d'aller au paradis c'est leur objectif
et eux considèrent leur vie sur terre
comme un passage comme une épreuve
pendant laquelle ils doivent accumuler
le maximum de de bonnes actions pour
avoir droit au Paradis vous croyez au
Paradis vous je crois en Dieu mais je
crois pas au Paradis pas qu'un jour on
va se retrouver au paradis avec plein de
gonzesses et de la bonne musique et tout
j'y croyez pas en tout cas il y a un
truc qui peut pas être votre paradis
avoue c'est partir en vacances avec
Laurence Ferrari
le paradis pour vous c'est quoi
aujourd'hui ma femme les filles
c'est très marrant d'ailleurs parce que
quand vous aviez pas de pognon vous
habitiez à Créteil et là vous en avez un
peu plus vous êtes resté à Créteil dans
un appartement plus grand c'est bien
ouais l'état devenu
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu